a terrorist house has clapped  they've also been damaged  firefighters have rescued four people  three people were taken to hospitals  office by london ambulance service  crews and a further person was treated  at the incident  firefighters carried out as a  substantial search of the property sadly  a child was pronounced dead at the scene  our thoughts with their family friends  and the local community at this time  the welfare of all involved in this  incident is very important to us  and us our staff will be offered  counselling as a matter of priority  around 40 properties have been evacuated  as a precaution and a 50 meter cauldron  is now in place  the brigade's 999 control officers took  14 calls for this incident  the brigade was called at eight minutes  past seven  and crews were on scene within three  minutes  unfortunately the cause of the fire and  explosion is not known at this time